and if you're a Connor fan it's the
perfect fight for him you know this is
one of those fights so you can see him
winning that's not like you sign up to
fight a Dustin Poirier just engage your
makachev this is a fight it's a winnable
fight he should be slightly favored in
it you just don't know what version of
counter you're gonna get now before his
injury against boy he didn't look
terrible and I assume Connor has enough
respect for himself he's not gonna sign
for a fight if he's not ready to go you
know so if your Connor fan is the right
choice now if he beats Tony which will
be favored to do it's Off to the Races
and then you'll see you're gonna get
conoverse Tony Ferguson then you get
carnivorous marketev you that mock Joe
fight Timmy tough yeah the hell price
right off in the sunset